if I may I should like to congratulate  all five of these distinguished  gentlemen for their outstanding  performances  Warren Beatty in Bonnie and Clyde Paul  Newman in Cool Hand Luke Dustin Hoffman  in the Graduate Spencer Tracy in guess  who's coming to dinner and Rod Steiger  in the heat of the night may I have the  envelope  Rod Steiger in  thank you  the Maharishi sir  thank you thank you thank you ladies and  gentlemen I thank you I find it  unbelievable I find it overwhelming and  I wish to thank the members of the  Academy for such an experience secondly  if my indulge myself I would like to  thank the people the public who've been  so kind to me thirdly I'd like to thank  Norman Jewison for his giving an act of  freedom to make a mistake fourthly and  most importantly I'd like to thank mr.  Sidney Poitier for the pleasure of his  friendship which gave me the knowledge  in understanding of prejudice in order  to enhance my performance thank you and  we shall overcome